and we wanted to talk to you today about
so what we've been doing recently in in
the public sector and in particular
using using machine learning and
analytics to to reduce our risk so just
a quick outline of the what we're going
to talk about so I'll introduce and the
problem that we're trying to solve and
it turns out this essentially boils down
to a kind of very traditional fraud
detection problem so I'll go through and
the kind of usual ways that you approach
those kind of problems and then I'll
show you how we we twist tweak it
slightly to to work specifically for our
case of of trying to identify and
actually low risk people and non fraud
effectively as compared to food and I'll
go through the different steps that we
go that we use in building our assurance
scoring and pipeline but first who are
we so my name is Mark Thompson i'm a
senior deck scientist at capgemini been
there for a couple years now and and i
have quite a few years of experience in
working in fraud detection like problems
and but i held back to a PhD in
astrophysics and my my first shame was
plug you know please like my paper it's
linked there it's awesome italian my
name is Natalia I have a PhD in optical
engineering I worked a few years in
academia in signal and image processing
and i joined capgemini last year as our
data scientist all right so we both work
in the big data analytics team we have
something like 30 or so data scientists
at the moment and something and around
40 big data engineers and fair to say
we're constantly growing so that number
is always changing and we really focus
on using open source and Big Data
technologies to and data science
techniques to kind of help our clients
solve their problems and and we've had
to be a sponsor of the conference as
well
alright so just to just to start off
with a bit of an introduction to the to
the problem that way that we're trying
to solve and so the public sector is
working in a constant environment of
trying to try to do more with less and
reduced reduced resources essentially
and populations are getting bigger
budgets are tight and so you want to
prove and you still want to provide a
better service and so you need to do
that with with much greater efficiency
and so it's really important to make
sure that you're the limited resources
that you do have are focused in the
right way and and that's really what the
kind of crooks of this assurance scoring
pipeline is it's it's shifting the the
resources that that are being expended
on on cases that and people that present
essentially no risk to to the to the
public and from from those low risk
cases onto onto high-risk cases and we
and we've developed a method to use as I
say to use machine learning and other
biological techniques to identify that
least at least Rick's risky and part of
the population realize that it's all a
bit abstract and i wish i could tell you
about specific examples that I can't so
we've kind of come up with a kind of
hypothetical example of how we might
apply this this technique and its
problem so so imagine that you're
running the process of the application
process of selling tickets to the 2016
olympics in a few months time so there
are the tickets for for the Olympics are
massively oversubscribed there are many
more and many more people wanting
tickets than there are tickets available
so you you have an application process
you you know i'm filling the form i'm at
thompson i want 10 tickets to go see the
fencing and i and i submit that
application and then it's the the kind
of system has to figure out who should
get the tickets and who
get the tickets and the vast majority of
people are will be completely genuine
and there will be but you want to avoid
selling two tickets to ticket touts and
ticket resellers so and so essentially
because they're so they're essentially
the ticket touts and resellers that are
are fraudulent people that people who
want to make money from from reselling
these tickets and we want to we want to
avoid that we also want to avoid the
approach of actually looking at each
each individual application that people
are people are sending in so that
essentially boils down to a kind of
fairly classic for a detection problem
but with a very large class imbalance we
typically typically talking a less than
kind of less than point one percent of
fraudulent cases sometimes a lot less
and so and so what we do is we say okay
well let's let's instead of trying to
trying to identify those very few high
risk/high fradulent cases actually let's
let's try and identify a group a larger
group are very very low-risk very non
fraudulent people so people who are very
unlikely to to be a ticket towel or a
ticket reseller and if we can identify
that group that means we don't need to
spend any resources or any money
investigating that group and they can be
shifted onto the onto the the high-risk
group that are more and yeah little more
risky and so I just thought I'd give a
quick quick reminder of the kind of
traditional fraud detection approach and
which I'm hoping most of you are kind of
fairly familiar with this is the ferry
it's a fairly standard diagram of
applying a supervised machine learning
profile and so we we start at the top
identify a historical training data
that's a that's going to be a label and
set of labeled data with people who we
who have committed fraud and that we can
train models on we then have a kind of
sure engineering steps so that's where
we build our we build our feature vector
and for each of those people so for each
person who's applying for these for
these tickets we will calculate
variables and for them things like the
number of tickets that they've applied
for or the number of tickets they bought
in the past something like that you
build your vet terminus I think fair to
say where you spend most of your time
and then you go through a kind of model
training and evaluation step where you
train your train your models and you
identify the model that gives you the
best performance and you and you can
then deploy it into a model execution
step which is where you you can for new
applications coming in for these for the
for these tickets you can you can
predict whether or not they're going to
be fraudulent or not and there's a
feedback process so that you can improve
your models throughout so that's and and
as I said so the traditional kind of
approaches will use this system will use
this method and will really try and
identify who's committing fraud and with
assurance growing we look to to focus on
the people who are not committing fraud
and that allows our resources to be
better focused and I'd also like to say
it's not limited to machine learning so
machine learning is kind of at its core
but all we can do is we can add a number
of steps after the machine learning
phase two to really make sure that our
low risk cases really are low risk and
I'll talk through that shortly I'm all
built using Python of course and we're
using the standard libraries and I
scikit-learn and so on um okay so so
hopefully I'm just going to talk through
this this diagram which tries to explain
the the pipeline that we see for these
cases so imagine that imagine that you
have a new batch of applications coming
in from the from the left-hand side here
you use a we use a machine learning
method to to classify those new
applications for tickets into into high
in low risk
and so that defines our initial hi and
Lois buckets and we then I then see this
is almost a kind of survival process so
we we really interrogate that low-risk
book it because we want to make sure
that those cases really are low risk
because we're not really going to do
much investigation on them so we can so
we look where you can use some kind of
some deterministic rules business rules
to to encode any additional logic that
we want to that might push cases out of
that Louis bucket into the high res
bucket we can apply statistical anomaly
detection techniques to identify batches
of applications that that we might not
want to consider low risk we can then
look for what we call great reversal is
essentially looking for links between
that high-risk bucket and any previous
sorry that low risk bucket and any
previous high-risk cases so and so
anyone that's any lowest person that is
linked to a high-risk person you might
want to kick out with that low risk
bucket and put into the high-risk cases
and so the idea is that if you're low
risk and bucket has been classified as
low risk by a machine learning model is
past your rules pass your anomaly
detection pasture or you're linking
questions and you can be pretty sure
that you're the final book you've got
really is low risk and so the rest of
this talk will be and essentially taking
you through each of those different
steps before we yeah but before we do
that and before we do any kind of
machine learning or analytics we need
data and so and one of the things that
we found really useful is to is to apply
an analytical data model which we call
the the pole model and don't know is
anyone come across this no okay and so a
lot of organizations big organizations
have a real problem with a lot of
different data sources spread across and
different silos different departments
and
and and and the key the key thing that
we do is we want to bring all that data
together so these data sources that say
imagine these are these are all data
sources at the bottom and it might be an
oracle database it might be a sequel
server database might be a might be a
set of csv files might be Twitter data
that you want to bring in and and you
want to bring all those all those
different data sources together into a
single place and that's what we've got
at the bottom here and that's great
that's really useful but it can still be
quite difficult to kind of identify the
links between those different data
sources and and also if we if we start
adding more data sources it kind of gets
it gets in you know it gets more
complicated as you add additional data
sources and so what we do instead is we
say well actually we're only we're
interested in particular attributes
within within these disparate data
sources and and so we define this this
this analytical data layer on top of our
and data warehouse essentially which is
the which is the pole model so pole
stands for person object location and
event and essentially what we do is we
go through each of these different data
sources and we pick out anything that
looks like a person and we promote it
into the person table this is basically
just a table in the database we go
through anything that looks like a
location and we put it in the location
table anything looks like event goes in
the event table and so for our example
you know a person is a / is someone
applying for tickets to the Olympics the
location might be the address that
they're applying from event might be the
actual the actual application itself and
and so on and the kind of benefit of
this is that if you add more more data
sources the complexity stays the same so
you can do your data science all on top
of this pole model and you don't need to
worry about you or any extra data
sources too much and and there's always
one thing that's that's missed off those
those kind of slides around the pole
model that is the relationships between
between the entities so there's a
relationship stable that defines
relationships between party and between
people and events between people of
parties and and location okay so now
we've got our now we've got our data and
it's time to do some to start building
our assurance scoring pipeline and we
start off with the machine learning
element machine learning is at its is
that it's really the core of the core of
the model and all core of the pipeline
rather and Natalia is going to take you
through how we build that thank you very
much so we've got our machine learning
part so we want to build a classifier so
we want to be able to discuss these
applications into the low risk buckets
on to the high risk buckets and we've
built this framework in Python so the
idea was to incorporate of course I
could learn for the model building
pandas for dates exploration but we also
wanted to have some built-in functions
that we could easily explore and test
techniques and we could understand and
know what will work and what it wouldn't
so the idea of the framework is that we
have some structure so as I said before
we can compare but it works and what it
doesn't and but it has some flexibility
so we can target our code and our
functions according to the data said
that we are working with we all know
that we need to do some data
pre-processing to our data set depending
on the problem at hand so we've done
that but what we didn't want was a
framework that would actually with the
click of a button will give you a model
now we wanted the person are the data
scientist rather you know to be there
too and specify the parameters of the
model to have control at every stage of
what was going on but the other feature
that we wanted was consistency so it
doesn't matter with data sources i'm
reading my data from doesn't matter what
data preprocessing i need to do what we
want is that at the end of the day I've
got my set of outputs it could be my
models we can have pickled models I have
log files for examples so we can rip
later on we can understand what happens
when we were building a model so we
wanted to have all these outputs and
this consistency across our framework of
course we did a all the testing with it
so you need testing we have some
monitoring testing and this is quite
important you know with your data we
kind of know what ranges you are
expecting so it's good to have these
checks so we say okay we've got this
column are we are we in range are we
that is the data size as I expected and
we know this is knowledge from the
business of this is all the contingency
plan just to make sure that all your
data flow is going as it should be
within this machine learning pipeline so
let's go into the future engineering so
we've got all this data and let's come
back to our Olympics example so we want
to we if we let's say we want to score
all the people applying for tickets on
the 2016 but we are going to use the
2012 Olympics data as a training data so
we already know which people have
actually been resellers so we have all
these data and what we want now is to be
able to identify what bits of
information are most relevant for this
classification problem and we tend to
spend a lot of time on this part really
so the idea is that we've got all these
historical data sorry this historical
data and we are going to transform and
the best advice here and is something
that we do with our clients is actually
try to incorporate the business
knowledge and the field expertise into
this process so we want to map for
example something that is happening in
real life you know this is a business
process and we are trying to attract a
feature a variable that will represent
this actual process and I don't know
probably you are aware of this and
feature engineering sometimes is known
as as an art and I believe this is true
you know this is an opportunity for us
as data scientists to incorporate
perhaps novel analytical techniques
sometimes we've used text analytics or
sentiment analysis we've tried network
analytics you know and trying to
incorporate new variables and new
features into into our models and we do
this you know is in an iterative process
and we kind of need to to know our data
and something that you may be aware of
it that you need strategies to actually
deal with outliers for example how to
deal with the null values and all this
and we have implemented all these
functions within our framework so we can
easily standardize our data and clean
our data and of course we the idea is to
build as many features as possible but
we all know that if we want our model to
be able to generalize well with with new
data we need to select some of these
features how we need to identify the
most relevant features and for example
cited learn has some a good test to
assess the significance of some of the
features you can run decision tree or
perhaps a random forest and then you see
the future importance so in this way you
can pre-select some of the features it
is very important and this happens a lot
we always validate the features we are
selecting with the product owners or
with the people in the business so we
are sure that we are integrating all
that knowledge and it's always good to
ask questions you know always questioned
your data is it really representing what
is going on it is really generalizing
the population and remember these we
don't want our model to perform well on
the data they have been trained for so
we don't want it to get all the 2012
resellers we want to be able to identify
the new ones coming on the 2016 so after
we've done this a fair system with the
feature selection we go into the model
building standard things we use
cross-validation we do this in
alliterative process we have our
training data set we divided in 3 we go
we use some part for training some part
from validation but something that we
find that is good practice is to have a
holdout test and this is a segment of
your training data that you do not use
for either feature extraction or to
train your model and the idea is that
then you can test and assess your models
on this new data set and we with the
idea of seeing how well your model is
going to generalize on new data within
our framework
we test different models and we use for
example grid search for hyper parameter
tune and we use all the features
built-in scikit-learn and once we've got
a set of models that we are happy with
we go and try to select the best one and
which one is the best model is the
million-dollar question isn't it and and
it really depends on day on the
application that we are working with and
something that is very important is to
understand how the output of the model
is going to be used in our case we have
a score for each of the applications and
we most likely the business process is
going to be to set a threshold in a way
that the cases that are below certain
score are considered to be low risk of
this they go to a different processing
center let's say and so they are going
to be a they don't need to be looked
into details but then we'll have the
higher risk bucket we're probably you
want to understand more what is
happening how do you set a threshold for
a classifier again it's very application
dependent sometimes we want to make sure
that the cases we put in the high-risk
bucket are really high risk and this is
called that we have a high precision but
sometimes you don't mind if you have one
of these green or lower risk cases into
your red bucket as long as you have as
many as you can of the high risk so then
you said your threshold or so again it's
very case dependent and what we've done
here is we've got our bucket so we say
okay let's set a threshold here and
we've got the business agreeing on this
and then we say okay let's put our
bucket here and our other bucket here
and then we apply further analytical
techniques to ensure that actually the
cases that are on this low risk buckets
are really low risk and this is what
matt is gonna tell us a bit more about
thank you okay so thanks and Talia say
so you finished you've changeable you've
trained your machine learning model
you've got your coat classifier for
running
and we're now going to start building
some of the extra extra parts of the
pipeline and so and the first one is
it's looking at essentially
deterministic rules and relatively
simple i appreciate but actually how a
lot of fraud detection in the past has
been done in this way and it allows you
to often get buy-in from from clients in
order to to help your machine learning
and classifier so you're not just using
a machine learning classifier and so the
particular example that i was going to
use is that and when you're looking for
looking forward to interactions near a
threshold so and this is a kind of
classic fraud detection problem in
accounting and so I imaginate an
expensive system so I you know I'm Matt
Thompson I'm staying at a hotel tonight
I'm going to submit an expense an
expense claim for that for that cost and
a lot of the time with inexpensive
systems you would look at em
transactions above a particular
threshold in more in more detail you
give them more scrutiny and so what a
fraudster can do is say well actually
Emily thresholds 100 pounds i'm going to
put a whole load of transactions through
at 90 pounds because i know that they're
not going to get scrutinized and i can i
can get away with my my fortune and
expense claim so what you might want to
do is is encoding sit you know you know
that behavior and so we can encode that
behavior directly explicitly and that
can be really helpful to to help our
help define that Louis bucket I mean
nearly big example say so I was going to
say so this this tends to end up being
kind of queries on your feature vector
see you we built the feature vector we
might as well use it to do more than
just our machine learning and and so we
might want to say that anyone applying
for more than 10,000 pounds worth of
with our tickets we couldn't want to
investigate in more detail and
regardless of what the machine learning
model says
okay so the next next step on this in
the pipeline is the statistical anomaly
detection so so I've got a really kind
of toy example here for what I mean by
that and essentially you can use the
training data to create a historical
baseline of say applications and within
it within a time window so applications
per day per month a week within a
particular postcode you use that to to
define your baseline and then if if you
get a set of applications or a batch of
applications from a particular postcode
and or or county or something that is
way off the charts compared to what you
and what you would normally expect you
might actually want to push all of those
cases from that lower ice bucket into
that high-risk bucket ok so when Ellie
there and so the the kind of final step
that we're going to go through today's
the they kind of what we call the graph
traversal and so essentially there we've
got our lowest bukit we've got a
high-risk bucket we want to see if
there's any way we can link a high-risk
case to sorry lowest case to it to a to
a high-risk case because if we can if we
can find a link we're going to push that
case out from our low-risk into a high
risk and we use a matching a
probabilistic matching approach and to
do that and it's actually quite a key
part of our and assurance scoring
pipeline is it's as I said at the start
bringing those disparate data sources
together and and so imagine the scenario
that you've got I've got to data sources
here and each with three attributes name
phone number and favorite sport and
imagine that the entity feel like in
data source one has been has been
classed as as high-risk entity in dates
those two has been classed as low-risk
and we then we then apply this
probabilistic match and we say well
actually the names are fairly similar
there's a bit of a misspelling the the
numbers are the phone numbers are
basically the same is just the last two
digits have been switched and okay the
favorite sports completely different but
maybe we don't care about that and so
you might say so imagine this is a
a match of say eighty percent and again
because we're because we're really
interested in in identifying a pure low
risk and low risk bucket we're quite
happy to accept a kind of low threshold
for this matching so we're quite happy
to say well they might not actually be
the same and but we're going to push
they push them out anyway and and we
find that a really valuable way to to
bring different data sources together
okay and so then we've got our so then
we've got our pipeline so we've built a
machine learning model we've applied our
with pride our rules we've built us an
ollie detection we've built our links
between the high risk bucket and the
lowest bucket so the idea is there any
any low risk cases that have got through
all of those steps unscathed and you
know we can really we can really say our
low risk and if you are if you want more
details we feel free to get in touch
with me and we also have published
recently an assurance scoring brochure
which kind of goes through all the
details that I've just talked about and
we're also in the middle of a blog
campaign and so we've got a few blogs
and published already again just going
into more details around all of this and
more are coming soon and that's it I
have two questions do you find yourself
looking at contributions behind features
for particular projection often sorry
sorry they find yourself looking at
contributions for a particular
projection of them in order to explain
why the reaction was made and how you
approach this and second one how do you
ensure replicability of all the models
you built if you do ya say so replicate
replicability I mean I guess I hope that
are well so we're building the model on
a single training set so you know so its
historical it's a single set of
Oracle data and we I mean we apply the
kind of cross-validation kind of methods
is that what you is that what you're
getting at or I'm not sure I'm not sure
where you mean exactly but we
essentially use cross-validation to to
ensure that our and test set that
Natalia was talking talking about
earlier to make sure that our models
generalized and that kind of thing and I
may have something there for example we
are lucky that we have a lot of data so
we have they reach in data so for
example what we've done also is test for
example in 2014 Zeta we also test some
features on the 2015 data you know so we
see that there are maybe perhaps if
there are variations in times are
actually the features are relevant you
know at different points in time so
we've also done that to ensure that
actually our models and our features are
representing the best the Zeta and the
problem at hand so that's another and in
answer to your first question around the
contribution we do look at that I think
it's fair today we probably do
relatively simply at the moment I've
just standard kind of chi squared type
stuff could you say something about how
you assign probabilities match
probabilities during the graph
traversals step so that's a bit tricky
we actually use a we actually use a a
product to do that and so I'm not the
expert on on how that works so if you
grab me offline I can I can point you in
to the right direction hi yeah I was
just curious because I mean obviously
you can't go into specifics for obvious
reasons but you focus on the example of
a specific service for risk models
whereas actually work in the public
sector and a lot of different services
might have the same [ __ ] profiles for
the people rather than the service again
yeah you're purchasing for so I mean how
much do you think the pose that you
taken is applicable to other public
sector services beyond a specific one
that you have trained your data well
yeah so I think it's I think it's really
really applicable to a number of
different areas and we say we've built
it right for a specific example but
we've built it in such a way that we
could we could apply it to all kinds of
different different use cases I think
it's I think it's very general it is
it's trying to solve a problem that it
generally exists within in public sector
systems
since fraud detection is quite an
adversarial thing that you detect people
and then people learn how often will
your model go out of date how much to be
training yeah it's pretty much the
out-of-date you soon as soon as you as
soon as you train it and so you have to
keep on top of that you have to
regularly refresh your your models in
your and your pipeline and then there's
not much you can do about that and
that's just the way it is is that a
significant cost or are you always
lagging behind it significant cut had
you minister I mean it's so if it takes
like a week to train it you can so it
doesn't oh no it doesn't take that well
so it it takes time yeah and of course
but it's not once once you've got the
kind of framework in place tweaking it
is relatively simple right so you
mentioned that sorry fancy yeah so you
mentioned your graph is graph database
yeah what's the reason for that as
opposed to in memory type graph for
example as opposed to in memory type
graphs okay I guess because so we have a
lot of data so we we we use neo4j in
particular because it's really good at
the fast query and when we want to do
things like network analytics we'd
probably move to more of a and the spark
graph right good and others in the
pipeline that do you do you train the
pipeline all our one saw you you do that
independently for example I appreciate
that the graph might take a while to
actually train often do you do that so
we build it in steps but we have to we
have to we also have to and make sure
that we train end-to-end say that we're
not in a biasing our results too much
okay there are no more questions thank
you very much methane italia